mais
non
il existe aujourd'hui autour du plateau
de saclay déjà un écosystème extrêmement
pertinent et fort d'industriels et
petites moyennes entreprises
positionnées sur la thématique de la
gestion énergétique intelligente et nous
avons formé dans ce cadre là un cluster
dont l'objectif est de progressivement
travailler avec l'établissement
d'aménagement du plateau de saclay le
pps pour fédérer une démarche efficacité
énergétique réseaux électriques
intelligents autour des infrastructures
du plateau de saclay donc on peut déjà
citer un certain nombre d'initiatives
très intéressantes dont notamment par
exemple avec le groupe bouygues
l'installation d'une très grande
centrale solaire au tour du challenger
en lien avec le plateau de saclay et
avec l'introduction d'un certain nombre
de véhicules électriques dans le cadre
d'un micro réseau autour du challenger
on peut citer aussi autour de l'institut
de recherche technologique systemx une
plateforme big data smart energy pour la
ville qui vient d'être lancé avec un
certain nombre d'acteurs industriels de
petites start-up qui porte notamment sur
le pilotage intelligent de la charge du
véhicule électrique ne vous voyez ici
par exemple un véhicule électrique
alstom connecter avec une borne de
charge giteau mobility qui sont deux
acteurs présents dans cette danse est
plate forme de liberté systemx et on
continue dans cette direction par
exemple avec le support au montage d'un
projet qui s'appelle live grid qui est
on va dire la conceptualisations d'une
démarche collaborative entre les
différents établissements de
l'université paris saclay pour partager
des informations en lien avec la
consommation énergétique sur ces sites
et faire émerger de la recherche en lien
avec les différents chercheurs
positionner dans des établissements
comme polytechnique centrale supélec ou
le cea et cette initiative est piloté
par edf
qui est en train de se repositionner
très fortement d'un point de vue r&d
dans le cadre de ce cluster énergies
autour du plateau de saclay donc c'est
une démarche en cours extrêmement
dynamique et qu'on souhaite
progressivement construire et on espère
que d'ici 2020 ça deviendra le le centre
de l'innovation dans le dans l'énergie
en france par exemple
peut-être dans le cadre de la future
exposition universelle où le plateau de
saclay dans le cadre du grand paris pour
être vraiment un très grand
démonstrateur d'écoquartier sur toutes
ces thématiques énergétique